Attorney General Jeff Sessions our buddy
might have committed perjury again
remember that Jeff Sessions just fired
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe for in
part this is just so funny lack of
candor during testimony we already know
that back in March of 2017 in a hearing
Jeff sessions said he had no
communication with Russians during the
Trump campaign we later learned that he
actually had multiple communications
with Russians this was the first live
from this sort of series of lies of
course there are lots of other Jeff
Sessions lies unrelated to this series
but just as a reminder this is how that
went down when being questioned by Al
Franken and if there is any evidence
that anyone affiliated with the Trump
campaign communicated with the Russian
government in the course of this
campaign what will you do
senator Franken I'm not aware of any of
those activities I have been called a
surrogate at a time or two in that
campaign and I did not have
communications with the Russians and I'm
unable to comment on total lie probably
perjury he'll never get in trouble for
it though fill the swamp and move on
okay we thought we were done and beyond
it but sessions testified again a couple
of times including in November of 2017
and that time it was before the House
Judiciary Committee and it appears that
sessions also lied during that hearing
he was asked about now indicted Trump
advisor George papadopolis Papadopoulos
had proposed that Donald Trump's
campaign reach out to Russia during that
meeting that took place on March 31st of
2016
Trump was at that meeting sessions was
at that meeting other top top Trump
staff were at that meeting sessions
claimed during the testimony that he
pushed back against them that he thought
reaching out to Russia was a bad idea
and that he wanted to make sure
everybody in the room knew that he
thought it was a bad idea unfortunately
it appears that that was also a lie
because Reuters is now reporting that
three people who were at the meeting
said now it's not true sessions
expressed no objection whatsoever to
reaching out to Russia and these three
individuals say they've also
spoken to Robert molars investigators
and told Robert molars team that it
wasn't true what Jeff sessions said he
posed no objection whatsoever to
reaching out to Russia now there is I
want to be thorough I'm not hiding
anything from you there's a fourth
person who is at the meeting who says no
no Jeff sessions is telling the truth he
did push back so currently it's three to
one on this issue we can think about who
to believe right do we believe the
recused Attorney General who's already
been caught lying or do we believe the
three people who were in the room and
were interviewed by Robert Moeller's
team and said no sessions didn't push
back at George papadopolis suggestion
that we reach out to Russia you judge
for yourself who you want to believe but
the really depressing part of all of
this is that no one's gonna go after
sessions for perjury right there have
been no consequences for sessions lies
back from March of 2017
there have been no consequences for
sessions for recusing himself on
anything related to Russia and then
firing people specifically to interfere
with the Russia investigation as
admitted by Donald Trump they currently
control every aspect of the government
they seem to be unable to control robert
muller which is good right like we hope
that they're not controlling robert
muller and that that investigation will
happen fully and fairly but we're not
gonna see anybody within trump's
administration hold jeff Sessions
accountable here for recusing and then
being involved and then lying once
during testimony to the Senate and once
during testimony at least once during
testimony to the house Trump could
remove sessions for the lies yeah right
and also we could argue that firing
sessions in a way might be a step
towards firing Muller but I think Pat we
just have to come to terms with the
reality that there's not going to be a
repercussion sessions for having done
this it's not gonna happen and
unfortunately I think sessions view of
in the public has been tarnished I agree
for a time even though we had
disagreements with him he could be seen
as a patriot because he did decide to
recuse himself he's not a complete
Lackey for Trump and it looked like he
wasn't willing to make those contacts
with Russia now we don't know what to
believe
yet there was a period of about three
and a half minutes that Pat's referring
to where we had plausible belief
of what Jeff sessions said before it was
instantly fact-check and realized he was
lying I mean let no it was longer than
three and a half minutes but you're
right like bye and it's not that I would
call him a patriot oh yeah but you're
saying as a straight and standard by the
standards of the committed trumpets
which are shifting standards by the way
you could sort of say like this guy is
not the worst guy out there but yeah
that's gone out the window and there
we're gonna have to just realize that
hopefully some people will be held
accountable for this entire thing that
is being investigated but we're gonna
have to come to terms with the reality
that a lot of them just or not they're
not going to be held accountable and
it's sad I don't know what else to tell
you I wish I had something else I could
say a word of inspiration but I don't
today's program is made possible in part
by Foote or which is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other to
predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or your web browser
you'll see a range of forecasts covering
topics across the board politics sports
everything in between you wager on
predictions about real-world events
using futur zin game fake currency and
you earn more of this currency every
time you make a prediction that comes
true and you can show off your
prediction skills to friends improve
your forecasting ability I'm even on
futur you can find my account and follow
me by clicking the link in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube this week on futur the question
I posed is will North Korea agree to
nuclear disarmament before the end of
July of 2018 before the end of July of
2018 what do you think click the link in
the description if you're watching on
YouTube place your bets you can also
browse the politics category on future
to make other wagers on predictions and
you can sign up at fut you you are calm
start making forecasts available on
Android iOS and your web browser